they dig to find survivors buried under
the mud but hopes of finding people
alive are fading fast dozens are missing
from this Village in Malawi after
tropical storm Freddy tore through it
I'm helping to find the victims I know
there are more bodies that are still
buried so far between 20 and 25 bodies
been recovered from the debris and
ruined houses most of them have been
ferry to the hospital but they all look
dead
Freddie is one of the strongest storms
ever recorded in the Southern Hemisphere
and the longest lasting little was
spared by the storm
it was too bad in the night but now that
it is daytime I can feel the loss I have
never seen something as terrible as this
my neighbor's house is Al organ the
family members are gone they are missing
in some cases the father is alive but
the wife and the children are gone
widespread flooding tens of thousands of
homes are damaged the UN says more than
half a million people could face a
humanitarian crisis in one of the
world's poorest Nations
in Malawi people have been urged to move
into temporary shelters and the
government has declared a state of
disaster
this is the second time this has
happened in 2015 we also experienced a
disaster but this time it's far worse I
think the number of dead here is likely
to rise
scientists say climate change is making
tropical storms more powerful as oceans
absorb heat from greenhouse gas
emissions here in Malawi many are
suffering the consequences despite
having done the least to cause it
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
the storm began 37 days ago in the
Western Pacific and has traveled more
than 8 000 kilometers gathering strength
over the Indian Ocean it made landfall
in Madagascar as a tropical cyclone and
from there moved on to batter Mozambique
for several days it then regained
strength in the Mozambique Channel and
hit the country again
so more on this we've got our senior
meteorologist to Everton Fox with us why
has this storm hung around for so long
well the key thing there you mentioned
was the Mozambique channel it's a very
warm body of water and of course we talk
about climate change Tory mentioned it
in her piece there that's with the with
the climate change warm Waters they're
even warmer than they should otherwise
be if you take a look at the satellite
picture you can see the position of the
storm now it's well away from the
Mozambique Channel but having gone in
and out of the Mozambique channel it's
been able to regenerate and gain more
strength and bounce its way back so if
we just move the picture on you can see
that actually about two days ago the
storm was finally downgraded so it is no
longer a tropical Cyclone but we do
still have plenty of rain to come and in
fact on the eastern coast of Mozambique
we saw 155 millimeters of rain in 24
hours and some parts could see a similar
amount over the next 24 hours you can
see the position of the storm as we go
through the remainder of Tuesday more
very heavy rain remain sliding across
Mozambique but a legacy of showers still
running their way all the way back into
Southern parts of Malawi eventually we
will start to see it push back out into
the Mozambique Channel but the winds
have dropped light as I say they really
have began to ease off noticeably now
we'll see some wetter weather gradually
making its way towards that western side
of Madagascar as we go on through the
next couple of days still the showers
there into Mozambique Southern parts of
Malawi but nowhere near as heavy as they
have been recently by Friday we should
gradually see things start to normalize
somewhat still a fair few showers there
into a good part of Madagascar and also
a good part of Maison beak Adrian but
things will slowly improve listen many
thanks indeed we'll see you again in a
few moments Everson Fox